Okay.
We are now going to look at an example of
the United States under Donald Trump becoming
reminiscent of sort of a weird mishmash of
[inaudible]
George Orwell's 1984 and Aldous Huxley's brave
new world.
I've talked about the differences between
those, uh, two books.
And this example is sort of a combination
of the two.
Vice president Mike Pence is now defending
the deficits that Trump first said he would
eliminate and later pretended weren't actually
ballooning Mike Pence.
Now saying that the deficits are part of the
massive economic growth plan that Donald Trump
is running with in the economy.
With this story, we can essentially S uh,
agree never to talk about debt and deficit
again if we don't want to because it is almost
like satire Saturday night live level defense
of the deficits that they say are terrible
when it's a democratic president that they
said they would eliminate, that they claimed
didn't explode under Trump even though they
did.
And now they are saying, right.
Yeah, well the deficit is up and it's part
of our plan and ultimately it's all gonna
work out here is Mike Pence on CNBC making
this case.
And we're going to do this as another sort
of disinformation propaganda debunking where
we'll go bit by bit because there's so much
here that's important to not allow yourself
to be tricked with.
So let's look at the first clip to start with
the economy.
Certainly the numbers are very strong and,
and, and the, the unemployment numbers in
particular, very impressive.
Uh, I wonder whether you feel though, uh,
a little bit of the gloss of impressiveness,
uh, needs to be removed because of the deficits
that the size of the deficit and the direction
that it's heading.
Well, we saw in the last administration that
a doubling of the national debt,
okay, so we actually have to stop it already.
This guy is sick.
This guy's a sick liar.
Did you notice the bait and switch there?
Pence was asked about the deficit, which has
exploded under Donald Trump.
And Mike Pence said, you know, under Obama
the debt doubled.
This is a bait and switch and it only works
if you are an uninformed person on this issue.
The deficit is the one year deficit or surplus
for that year's budget that adds to or takes
away from the national debt.
If you go into a year with $100 in debt and
run a $10 deficit, your debt at the end of
that second year becomes $110.
If in the next year you reduce the deficit
to $8 you've reduced the deficit by 20% from
$10 to $8 but you've accumulated another $8
in total debt, meaning at the end of year
two, you now have $118 in debt.
A president can slow deficit growth or reverse
it, but that can even still not pay off the
debt in four years or even eight years.
So Barack Obama drastically slowed deficit
growth, but of course, if you have a deficit
at all, the debt keeps accumulating.
Year over year, Penn's was asked about the
deficit going up under Donald Trump, which
it did.
And Penn says, the debt went up under Barack
Obama.
He's a sick liar.
Let's continue
a doubling of the national debt.
But we also saw an American economy that wasn't
growing by more than 2% it was the slowest
economic recovery since the great depression.
Okay, so they claim again, Obama's recovery
was a recovery, but it was a very slow recovery.
It wasn't really a good one.
This is also a lie.
The stock market during Barack Obama's first
three years performed better than the stock
market.
During Donald Trump's first three years deficit
growth slowed under Obama deficit growth exploded
under Donald Trump.
Job creation at the end of Barack Obama's
presidency was actually stronger than what
Trump has had so far.
We're going to deal with that on tomorrow
or Wednesday's program, so even more lies.
Let's continue because this continues to build
up to this idea that, Oh no, the deficits
are just part of the growth plan that we have
and the president came into office and he
said, first and foremost, we have to restore
growth.
That's how we will deal with the longterm
fiscal challenges facing our country and deficits
and debt are are right in line, but it's first
about getting this economy moving again and
we really do believe the trajectory of this
economy.
We're going to end the next year in the 3%
range, which is what president Trump said
back on the campaign trail in 16
so now Mike Pence is claiming Trump promised
3% GDP growth.
And the reason that he's doing this make no
mistake is because they just got the 2019
numbers and it was 2.9% GDP growth.
So now Penn says Trump promised three this
is a lie.
Trump promised four or five and even 6% GDP
growth during the campaign.
He promised it after being in office.
Check out just one example of this.
Get it going the way I really want, where
we have GDP, getting up to four or five and
even 6% because I think that's possible.
If you look back in your notes, you'll say,
when I said 4% uh, people said that would
be years.
Well, it's turned out that I'm right because
without the hurricanes, this last quarter,
we would have had 4%
Pence is pretending that Trump promised three
and that they hit it or almost hit that goal.
It's lies, lies, lies.
Trump promised four from promised five, Trump
promised six.
So now we are finally getting to the conclusion
and you will notice that Pence doesn't even
use the language deficit and debt.
He just keeps referring to fiscal challenges
and he says growth is how we will deal with
fiscal challenges.
He's finally acknowledging the deficit explosion
without actually saying he's acknowledging
it and saying growth is the plan,
the deficit as a percentage of GDP though
has, has ticked up each year, this first term.
Would you like to see it as a focus for the
second term?
Uh, if you win one to, to change the direction
of that?
Well, I think the president's been very clear
and we've, uh, we've sharpened our pencils
on our budgets and we'll continue to do that.
Uh, and in a second term we'll continue to
address those issues.
But, but president Trump really believes that
the, the real longterm solution to the fiscal
challenges in Washington DC is making sure
that the budget of every American is growing
and you know, real income after tax income
for working families, it's actually increased
by $5,000 a year in the last three years.
And so the president's gonna stay focused
on a growing American economy.
And once we get this economy roll, and we're
going to continue to hold Congress to account,
and we're going to work real hard, not just
to get president Donald Trump four more years
in the white house, but we're going to make
sure that we have a Republican Senate and
a Republican house to keep America growing
and to deal with those longterm fiscal challenge.
So look at this for decades, Republicans say
the deficits terrible.
We've got to get a surplus.
We've got to pay off the debt.
We've got to cut everything and cut our way
out of debt.
Trump actually promises to pay off the debt
within eight years.
Only the most uninformed person would buy
that as a real possibility.
Unfortunately, many of his voters were uninformed
and they bought it.
Uh, the deficit explodes.
Trump says, well, the growth that my tax cuts
are going to, uh, stimulate will reduce.
The deficit doesn't happen.
Does the tax cuts blows up the deficit anyway,
the growth doesn't happen.
They deny that the deficit has exploded.
Now they can't deny it anymore.
So they say, well, this is all part of the
plan and the eventual growth that the tax
cuts are going to cause is going to deal with
it.
No economist worth, uh, worth their weight
in salt.
Nevermind gold believes that that's going
to happen.
They have lost the right to ever talk about
the debt and deficit again.
Republicans in Washington care about the deficit.
When the president is a Democrat and they
stop caring two seconds after a Republican
is in the, in the oval office.
This has been happening for a long time.
I believe it started under under Reagan, if
not before.
And if you look at this from a political standpoint,
why would they stop?
I mean, it's, it's completely inconsistent.
It's complete hypocrisy, but it doesn't hurt
them.
When it's useful to them to talk about debt
and deficit.
If a Democrat is the president or if they
want to claim that they are going to pay this
off or pay that off, then they just do it
and they get rewarded for it, rewarded for
it electorally.
Then they blow up the deficit and in some
way they justify it and people are either
too stupid or willingly ignorant and they
just go along with it.
With Bush it was like, well listen, you know
we had to do this Iraq war and that.
That was expensive.
We did, what do you mean we had to do it?
We went after a country that had nothing to
do with nine 11 and had no WMDs.
That was what we had to do it.
What are you talking about under Trump?
Either you deny it's happening as is increasingly
popular.
At least with my Trump, his followers, they
say no that the debts, the deficit is not
up yet is there's just find the reports.
It's public information or they say in the
longer term.
In the medium term.
The reasons that we have a larger deficit
now are going to create all this growth and
it'll all work out, which is just not happening.
It's been years already and it's just not
going to happen.
Why would they stop doing it when it continues
to be useful to them electorally, they won't
stop doing it.